we've got stagecoach we've got
Bachelorette premiere details and we've
got Winterfell it's time for roses and
rose hey you guys i can'ts nothing about
Game of Thrones I'm so sorry I know
we're here to talk about the
Bachelorette and we're gonna get to it
but did you wash don't you watch
so guys I'm Lauren Zima and Game of
Thrones talk aside we are here to
discuss Bachelorette news that you can
booze what a weekend we had so many
battles we had end game I haven't seen
it yet please don't give me the spoilers
you know the rule you're not supposed to
do the spoilers I haven't seen it I'm
going to see it this week three hours is
a really big time commitment okay
especially when I had Winterfell deal
with we had endgame we had Winterfell we
had 50 you guys up on fifty fifty Cent
versus while I can't Bravo
versus rapper battle man it was a
stressful weekend I need a drink
[Music]
we have my self-care wineglass today
because wow wow wow wow
I was watching Game of Thrones all
weekend re watching it in preparation
for the big battle is coming okay I
won't spoil it but I am going to
incorporate it into everything I say
today the incorporations might be Liz
they might be rough just like the
episode just kidding no it was a great
episode okay without spoiling and I'm
just gonna say the end of the episode
has me wondering how I'm going to be
excited for the next three episodes of
the series because the end was big and
it was what I thought would be I'm
getting into spoiler territory now turn
away for a minute turn away but come
back the end was big and I thought that
that would be the end of the whole
series and now I just I don't care about
Cersei I don't care about her I don't
need to fight her I just wanted to fight
the night king okay just in case I don't
want to spoil it tweet at me I love to
talk about it I need a drink
drink every time and make a loose foot
kind of the air Game of Thrones
reference during our Bachelorette news
update today please drink responsibly
just like Jorah was responsible for
daddy if i was a knight this would be my
crest this is it
this is my house I'm the house of rose a
maybe a rose in the middle there okay
moving forward let's give you a little
update so if you thought bachelor nation
turned out for Coachella you should see
them at stagecoach oh my gosh the news
you can booze is that bachelor and
bachelorette alumni turns it out for
stagecoach it is a music fest that slike
built for bachelor nation right because
a lot of ulam bachelor nation like we
have a little countryside to us and who
was there Amanda Stanton Andi Dorfman
Corinne elympios Colton underwear and
Cassie Randolph Blake Horstman I could
go on and is stagecoach their Winterfell
is it their battle it's the land of fire
they've got to get some ice which would
be a drink and it's a battle between who
can get closest to this stage and the
stage is the fortress nope I've lost it
so everybody's at stagecoach but what's
going on most importantly with our
upcoming season of The Bachelorette
Hannah Brown season season 15 so we have
some updates we have some news we have
some things we know for sure we have
Bachelorette
yes we do yes me too yes we do
it is that the show was going to Europe
- and to Latvia is that in Europe I
think it is it is who's been to Latvia
what happens in Latvia I don't know but
the bachelorettes gonna shine a
spotlight on it so it might be a country
that we should consider going to what am
I talking about we have gotten some
deets from ABC about things that are
gonna go down on Hannah season they will
be traveling to Scotland the Netherlands
choking myself Latvia and Greece also
known as Westeros and Dawn and the north
and the south one of you do this that's
magic the Lord of Light you shine your
light on your Jose if you can see
through it and that's the best kind the
clearest kind
a lot of lights gonna make sure I don't
drop this because he's got but okay I
I'm proud of myself for that
my sword work is that what it should be
I'm no aria that wasn't the spoiler I
don't know how to use it
sticking with the pointy end
how about Brienne for Bachelorette
that's the series I'd watch JC be
watching Game of Thrones oh here's what
I did guys I felt I actually didn't used
to watch Game of Thrones and I felt I
was missing a cultural moment and so
last year I watched all seven seasons in
two weeks
I slept about two hours a night and I
was talking to dragons that weren't
there but let me tell you I didn't even
need any Rose a for that mental trip
please watch Game of Thrones responsibly
don't do what I did okay self care other
Bachelorette news you can booze open
phone open we've also found out these
celebrity guests that we are going to
have this season
they include American Pie star Jason
Biggs and his wife Jenny Mollen and then
we're going to have Boston Celtics stars
Jalen Brown and Terry Rozier
fast-forward through that part sorry
sports fans I've got my mischance of two
or three favorites and guess what I'm
not telling then we're gonna have a
runway legend Miss J if you watched
America's Next Top Model originally Miss
J was a fixture on that show and Miss J
is coming to the Bachelorette
I love this I hope miss J teaches the
guys how to properly cat walk a runway
right to Hanna's heart miss J is our
son's a stock yeah
beautiful strong smart sassy making
things happen in the keep and then we
are also going to have oh the drag
queens of the moment Alyssa Edwards and
Alaska Alyssa we're in the company of
some amazing Queens tonight where I'll
be honest I don't know who they are but
I will be familiarizing myself and they
are our ooh
they are Robb Stark and our Jon Snow
good-looking war heroes very amazing
we'll pretend that Rob is not dead that
isn't a spoiler alert that having a lot
of seasons ago okay what other
bachelorette news do we have
we know locations we know celebrity
guests and we know a couple of bachelor
alumni who are appearing in the premiere
miss Demi Burnett and miss Katie Morton
remember as much but she's the one who
was dropped on that conversation between
Kaylin and Cassie and talked about it
davon in the vans they allegedly wanted
to be the Bachelorette and instead of
getting Colton's love for real blah blah
Katie to set the record straight The
Bachelorette conversation did happen on
the bus from the airport in Singapore to
the hotel so Demi and Katie are going to
be in a surveillance van on night one
listening to some convos that Hannah
might not have the time to listen to
herself they are known as Hannah's
angels there are her besties they have
her best interest at heart
so they like Tyrion and I think his name
is Varys that bald guy and they're like
the hands of the Queen Hannah you've
really got to watch the show tonight I'm
talking about now please be watching
Game of Thrones I love when we have a
crossover moment that you guys are with
me on like when we talked about Taylor
Swift and I think we have talked about
Game of Thrones before on this show I
think we might have talked about it when
Jessie J sees nodding we did something
at the theme before too didn't we we did
okay and
is a bachelorette we cannot wait for the
season premiere May 13th Hannah is going
to be looking for fierce love and she
will be in Lafayette why what's there
what's in Latvia I'm not think about it
I got to do some googling I don't know
the cuisine the culture uncultured swine
I'm like a peasant in the capital and I
don't know anything I hate oh god I'm so
sorry it's all I can think about today
I'm going to be seeing dragons on my way
home please leave your comments and
thoughts below on both the game of
thrones big Battle of Winterfell episode
also known as the long night and leave
your thoughts on what's gonna be the
long wonderful night of Hannah's
Bachelorette premiere may 13th
are you excited that Demi and Katie are
the choices for this first time ever
moment of them being inside the van
listening to the condos for Hannah
I think Demi's gonna be great because
she's deaf me and she says hilarious
crap and Katie an unexpected choice
there were things that I had heard and
actions that I had seen and I actually
think Katie could be good because we
know girls got a listening ear we know
she heard a conversation in a van before
I was mainly talking about Kalyn and
Cassie between Galen and Cassie we know
that they're gonna make a bunch of jokes
about that just like I'm doing right now
she's like crap what's the got Disney
we're skiing Thrones you guys don't
watch Game of Thrones nobody in a screen
studio watches Game of Thrones
Wow I'm like talking to myself this
whole time okay
she is who's the guy who is the Katie is
the guy Baelish Lord Baelish got Lord
Byron Lord Byron is in Latvia hanging
out with Littlefinger not right okay
so Katie is a little finger she's like
got all the info like little tricks and
she's got a lot to think about it saying
plans in people's minds she did it to
all of us at the women tell oh so what
will happen I'm so excited for night one
I'm not as excited for the final three
episodes of Game of Thrones but I'd like
to get more excited please leave your
comments below what do you think is
gonna happen do you think that the night
king will return do you think of the
battle with the dead is over do you
think the brand was the night king at
the end of the day or was that just a
theory and it's all gone to crap now are
you excited to see them go up against
Searcy for the last war as opposed to
the great war I'm sorry but I was just
ready for the great war and I thought
the night King was the one that we were
supposed to be fighting against this
whole time for two years they built it
up to me this is the only battle it
matters isn't the only violent matter
till now so we're starting my supposed
to do I know
maybe I will have that drink that was a
torment move that's how he would drink
and he'd sent down his ale like that my
name is cut off someone's head because
he could or rip their face off with his
teeth because he can do that too
honestly Game of Thrones is like an
episode of The Bachelor
there's a jillion dudes and you don't
know their names until like halfway
through when one of them gets eliminated
what a fabulous fabulous time it is we
are in the middle of Game of Thrones we
are getting the Bachelorette big a
little lies comes back in June I'm still
watching veep that's still happening
what are your favorite shows what are
you guys into tell me what you like as
we await the season premiere of The
Bachelorette that's all that I have to
say right now and I love you so much bye
oh yeah
and shameless plug I'm on cameo and if
you want to buy cameos do it because it
helps me buy more Rosie
the night king he's coming the dead are
already here he had a man burn a man
banana gone dead I am Lauren Zima first
of my name
protector of bachelor nation guardian of
Bravo's Real Housewives keeper of the
case of rose' that's in my refrigerator
now and of course queen of the house
[Music]
you